England's oldest national flag, the St.
George flag, red cross on white banner,
is currently embroiled in controversy,
particularly in the context of that
nation's migrant crisis. The more some
Brits raise it aloft, the more others
complain. Those waving it say they are
simply showing pride in being English,
reclaiming a symbol that represents
national unity, heritage, and
patriotism. No different from when other
peoples of other nations fly their
flags. Their detractors, however, most
of whom are inherently anti-English,
even if they have English DNA, claim
that the flag is representative of
far-right racist and xenophobic
tendencies, that it symbolizes exclusion
or hostility for migrants, the
overwhelming majority of whom are
Muslim. The truth appears to be
somewhere in the middle. English
patriots are indeed turning to their
nation's oldest flag as a collective
show of patriotic defiance against what
they see as an Islamic migrant takeover
where Muslims are used to destroy their
nation, groom their women, and suppress
English, specifically Christian culture
and heritage. Meanwhile, the greater
irony is that both groups fail to
realize that in its origin, the St.
George flag was born precisely in the
context of Christian defenders fighting
against Islamic aggressors. Here we must
turn to that forgotten that is
intentionally suppressed and/or
distorted discipline of history. The St.
George flag originated in the Middle
Ages as a military and religious emblem
inseparable from the Crusades. The
Knights of the Temple or Templars who
were founded in the early 12th century
were the first to adopt it. As chased
monks, white symbolized their purity.
And as men committed to fighting Muslims
to the death in defense of Christendom,
the red cross symbolized their
willingness to embrace martyrdom, which
a great many of them did over the course
of nearly two centuries. In the years
following the Templar's adoption of the
red cross on white, that emblem became
popular for other crusaders and for the
very same reason. It also came to be
associated with St. George, a 3rd 4th
century Christian soldier who was
martyed by the pagan Roman Empire for
refusing to renounce Christ. In the
medieval era, he naturally became a
symbolic figure representing Christian
militancy and the willingness to be
martyed for Christ in the fight against
Islam. Indeed, from the very start, St.
George was consistently portrayed as a
celestial knight who literally fought
beside the crusaders of the crusader
storming of Muslim held Jerusalem in
1099. Raymond of Aguiler a participant
and eyewitness of the first crusade
wrote that quote the blessed George was
seen in the army of Christ fighting
against the sariss and giving victory to
the faithful. Nearly a century later
during the third crusade around 1190 the
English king Richard I the Lionhe heart
regularly invoked George as his patron
saint. His men also believe that the
warrior saint fought alongside them. In
the words of another contemporary
chronicler, quote, St. George, the
standardbearer of the heavenly army,
came to the aid of the Christians and
overthrew the enemies of the cross.
Nearly a century after that, during the
9th Crusade around 1270, Prince Edward,
who would later become king of England,
was especially devoted to and quote
commended himself and his men to the
most blessed martyr, George, whom he had
ever taken as his special patron in war.
To quote from another contemporary
source, on returning to and becoming
king of England, Edward I continued to
officially endorse and use St. George as
a symbol of chivalry, military courage,
and martyrdom against anti-Christian
forces. So did his descendants,
especially his grandson Edward III. And
before long, certainly no later than the
mid 1300s, St. George and his banner
blood red cross on white became central
to English identity and represented the
militant protection of Christian England
against external threats with Muslims as
the paragonss for centuries thereafter.
The warrior saints flag inspired
courage, chivalry and a distinctly
English sense of marshall and religious
identity. Because the blood red cross
and white flag originated with the
Templars who formed the subject of my
latest book, The Two Swords of Christ,
we close with an anecdote concerning
those original knights of Christ and how
even Muslims were aware of and feared
St. George. In 1187, a vastly
outnumbered group of some 500 crusaders
led by the Templars were ambushed by a
massive Muslim army of some 7,000
fighters near Nazareth. Although the
crusaders and especially the Templars
made a valiant stand, they were all
heuned down until only one Templar
knight was left standing. He scorned the
offer of surrender and continued
fighting, forming a ring of dead
jihadists around him to the point that
the odd Muslims were convinced he was
St. George. In the words of the author
of the contemporary itinerarium, Perig
Vernorum, quote, "While the rest of his
fellow knights, estimated to number 500,
had either been captured or killed, he
bore all the force of the battle alone
and shown out as a glorious champion for
the law of his god. He was surrounded by
enemy troops and almost abandoned by
human aid. But when he saw so many
thousands running towards him from all
directions, he strengthened his resolve
and courageously undertook the battle,
one man against all. His commendable
courage won him his enemy's approval.
Many were sorry for him and
affectionately urged him to surrender,
but he ignored their urgings, for he was
not afraid to die for Christ. At long
last, crushed rather than conquered by
spears, stones, and lances, he sank to
the ground and joyfully passed to heaven
with a martyr's crown. triumphant. It
was indeed a gentle death with no place
for sorrow, when one man's sword had
constructed such a great crown for
himself from the enemy crowd laid all
around him. Death is sweet when the
victor lies encircled by the impious
people he has slain with his victorious
right hand. And because it so happened
that the warrior had been riding a white
horse and had white armor and weapons,
the Gentiles, meaning the Muslims, who
knew that St. George had disappearance
in battle boasted that they had killed
the knight of shining armor, the
protector of the Christians. Such is the
true origin of England's St. George
flag. It was forged in centuries of
warfare against and martyrdom at the
hands of Muslims. Incidentally, that a
Christian saint is tied to a European
nation's long war against Islam, in this
case, England's should be unsurprising.
The need for warrior saints was rather
ubiquitous across Christendom. One need
only look to Spain's patron saint, St.
James Matamorus. That is St. James the
Moore, meaning Muslim slayer. Check out
my video on him and how he inspired and
according to the Spaniards of history,
spearheaded the centuries long crusade
or reconista to evict Islam out of
Spain. At any rate, the point here is
that the St. George flag is much more
applicable to England's Muslim migrant
crisis than most English men and women
waving it can even begin to comprehend.
Put differently, the St. George flag is
a stark reminder that those who forget
history are doomed to repeat it.
[Music]